I'm a big believer in momentum and you
need to take time and think but
sometimes just trial and figuring it out
as you go
like I think talk is cheap and you learn
a lot by action hi my name is Noah craft
I'm 29 and I'm the CEO and co-founder of
Doppler labs Doppler Labs is an audio
technology company and what we have done
is created the first computer for the
ears we've created this product called
here.one and the basic premise is a
all-in-one listening system that you can
leave in your ears to stream music take
phone calls but also interact with the
world around when we founded this
company we believe that the third wave
of computing is gonna happen on the body
everyone's talking about wearables but
most of the focus is on the eyes and the
wrist and we made a bet early on that
the ears were actually a more elegant
place because people have worn
headphones for 65 years
[Music]
so my background is not in technology I
grew up in the film and music industry
and I kind of found myself at a very
early age you know running a hundred and
twenty person film set on a film set you
have these very kind of disparate groups
of individuals there's different
temperaments and different expectations
and I had to learn to manage that across
a holistic film set and now that I find
myself as the CEO of a company that's
very end to end with marketing sales
software firmware hardware electrical
mechanical and I never thought working a
film set would apply to a tech company
but it's oddly been a really helpful
learning experience where I think I got
some kind of core skills that I've been
applying as I've been trying to figure
out this next journey
there's I think huge risk and future
warden hardware you really just got to
go for it with hardware there's a point
where you just have to start cutting
steel literally and release cultural
innovation I think is as important to
tech innovation especially when we talk
about tech on the body because you have
to wear it and if you don't wear it
proudly and it's not something you
embrace then it's truly just a gadget
and that's not what we want to be
[Music]
there's so much stock stacked against
you as an entrepreneur at certain times
specifically just will yourself to the
next phase I like control I hold myself
to probably an absurd standard you know
I'm the guy who's always gonna say we
can do five percent better you don't get
many opportunities to go for something
big I don't care if it's Apple or
Microsoft we're not a start-up or a
company that's going to be at that level
and we need to hold ourselves to that
level starting now
[Music]
you